on this saturday night the precious
packages on their way to canada
the logistics to protect the vaccine
even something simple like
jostling the vials can destroy the
vaccine
so it can eventually protect canadians
the neurological
impact of the virus it feels like your
brain is broken what canadian scientists
are discovering plus a granddaughter's
love
people are reaching out to their seniors
in their life that's all i could ever
ask
for and how it set off a chain reaction
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the kovid 19 vaccine is on a journey
from belgium
to canada the first doses of the pfizer
biontech vaccine are set to arrive
on monday to begin inoculating those at
high risk
further shipments will be coming by the
end of the year but as jeff semple
explains
transporting the shots is a delicate
process
less than two weeks till christmas and
ups workers are preparing for a very
special delivery
but instead of santa this package is
from pfizer and biontech
these photos show the first shipment of
covid19 vaccines
on its way to canada we have finally a
light at the end of the tunnel
thirty thousand doses were picked up
from pfizer's factory in belgium on
friday
and sent to germany for processing from
there they're heading to a ups
international logistics hub in kentucky
transported in these
high-tech coolers to keep the vaccine at
minus
70 degrees it's a shipper box about the
size of like a carry-on suitcase and
then there's dry ice that goes around it
and then it has actually a device within
it that has a continuous
gps and temperature monitor so we will
be able to have
continuous eyes on every shipper by
monday the vaccines will likely begin
arriving
at these 14 delivery sites across canada
except for the territories because of
challenges with cold
storage you have to have the cold chain
with special refrigerators
and the other thing that's important is
that when you do thaw the
vaccine to give it it's very unstable so
even something simply like
jostling the vials can destroy the
vaccine
health canada also warned anyone with
allergies to the vaccine's ingredients
should avoid it after two negative
reactions in the uk
as far as the risk of allergies
we do list all the products that are in
our vaccine so that
people can see if they have a history
against any of those ingredients
the company also concedes it's unsure
how long the vaccine's immunity will
last
the ceo telling cnn patients may require
a repeat i would not say seasonal but
maybe every two years but if all goes
according to plan
some at-risk canadians could begin
receiving the vaccine
as early as monday and not a moment
too soon shoppers in alberta
and york region near toronto crowded
into malls
a sudden christmas shopping rush sparked
by the news their communities are
heading into lockdown
trying to get in there before it closes
on monday uncle mike how are you doing
alberta just launched this colorful new
ad campaign
warning that nobody loves a holiday
gathering more than
covid with canada's case count projected
to climb up to 12
000 per day by early january
jeff semple global news toronto it will
be well
into the new year before most canadians
can be vaccinated so we need to keep
following health guidelines
in many parts of canada we are nowhere
close to flattening
the curve both quebec and ontario
recorded nearly 1900 cases today
manitoba reported 360 new infections
there were 274 new cases in saskatchewan
alberta reported 1590 cases today
bc does not report on weekends
the united states surpassed 16 million
covet 19 cases today
so the fda approval of the pfizer
biontech vaccine couldn't come soon
enough it's a major turning point in a
pandemic that has claimed nearly
300 000 lives in the u.s but it
reportedly took threats from the white
house
to get those vaccines rolling out
jennifer johnson reports
as about three thousand americans a day
die of covet 19
the u.s food and drug administration
commissioner took to the airwaves
assuring americans the just-approved
pfizer biontech vaccine is safe
and is the country's best weapon against
this virus science and data
guided the fda's decision we worked
quickly based on the urgency of this
pandemic
not because of any other external
pressure
on twitter u.s president donald trump
did pressure dr hahn
there were reports the white house
threatened to fire him if the vaccine
didn't get approved friday
the fda chief dismissed those stories as
the rollout of the doses begins
we expect 145 sites across
all the states to receive vaccine
on monday another 425
sites on tuesday and the final 66
sites on wednesday emergency room dr ben
usach will be one of the first in his
state colorado to be vaccinated
i am going to be one of the tips of the
spear one of the first people
to step in to help generate this herd
immunity
which is so important to us to get a
grip on this terrible disease
already there are concerns there won't
be enough vaccines initially for all
health care workers and nursing home
residents
pfizer biontec is exploring ways to
scale up manufacturing
we remind the public to remain vigilant
as inoculation will take time
wear a mask wash your hands and remain
socially distant when possible
the virus is spreading so rapidly
several states are out of icu beds
many morgues are filled to capacity this
one in fort worth texas
is racing to double its space doctors
fear what's ahead
as the christmas holiday approaches as
physicians we've been trained to
help people and it's really hard right
now to feel
helpless millions more vaccine doses may
be available soon
modernist vaccine goes before the fda's
advisory panel for review december 17th
as america's grim death toll continues
to rise
jennifer johnson global news washington
mexico one of the worst-hit countries in
latin america has
also authorized the vaccine for
emergency use it will receive 250
000 doses initially enough to vaccinate
125 000 people
frontline health workers will be the
first to get the shots
the government has faced harsh criticism
for its handling of the pandemic
as case numbers and deaths keep rising
mexico has the fourth highest death toll
in the world with more than 113
000 lives lost to coven 19. the rate of
fatalities is higher than any other
country
9.2 percent and the average age of those
dying in that country
is 55 it's 75 in much of europe
the development and approval of the
coven 19 vaccine happened at an
unprecedented pace think about it it's
been less than a year since the novel
coronavirus
was discovered and genetically mapped to
give you an idea of how that compares it
took
four years for the first successful
mumps vaccine to go from development
to approval the earliest development of
a polio vaccine began in 1935
but it wasn't until 1955 that an
effective vaccine was administered to
the public
and although there are treatments to
prevent the transmission of hiv
there is still no vaccine against that
virus
nearly four decades after it was first
discovered
the head of pfizer canada says ottawa's
policies are the reason why innovative
new vaccines are not being manufactured
in this country there was a time in
history when canada had its own domestic
production
and as scientists realize this vicious
virus isn't going anywhere
is it time to make vaccines here at home
let's go to mercedes stevenson and talk
about her interview
with the head of the canadian division
advisor mercedes
that's right we spoke with the head of
pfizer canada cole pinno
he says that pfizer has successfully
partnered with the trudeau government
to swiftly bring the covid19 vaccine to
canada
but when i asked him why there isn't a
pharmaceutical facility in
canada capable of manufacturing the new
vaccine he put the blame
squarely on ottawa saying the
government's policies deter
investment and innovation and that he's
very concerned about new drug
pricing changes which will come into
effect this january
pharmaceutical companies are concerned
that by setting a ceiling on prices
innovative new medicines will not launch
in canada
and that that will quote deprive
patients of potentially
life-changing new treatments we're very
concerned with the proposed changes to
the pricing reform pmprb as it's called
that is due to go to and go into effect
on january 1st
this type of further restriction on the
incentives
to bring innovative new products to
canada
really jeopardizes canadians opportunity
to have breakthrough medicines and other
therapies
moving forward so we'd really like to
partner with the government
unfortunately over the past four years
we haven't been able to engage in a
meaningful conversation
the government says that the new pricing
guidelines that mr pinno is talking
about
will reduce the cost of drugs for
canadians by some
13 billion dollars procurement minister
anita anand defended her government's
work to procure covet 19 vaccines
and highlighted efforts to boost
canada's ability to develop
pharmaceuticals here at home
we have invested 126 million dollars
in the nml facility in montreal
as well as millions of dollars in
research
facilities across the country including
in vito
interva out west so we are working
on a two-track system to make sure we
have a very diverse portfolio
of vaccines on the one hand and
investing in domestic manufacturing and
research on the other
the head of pfizer canada says he wants
to work with ottawa on a proposal to
develop
domestic manufacturing capabilities so
that canada would be
in a better position if there's another
pandemic
robin mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
today is the fifth anniversary of the
paris climate agreement
and world leaders are marking the
milestone with a virtual gathering
the climate ambition summit includes
representatives from more than 70
countries including canada
all of them are pledging to increase
their efforts to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
all of our countries are dealing with
the health and economic impacts of the
global pandemic
but as we look to rebuilding from this
crisis we must do so in a way that will
build back
better for all of our citizens and that
must
include an ambitious plan to take strong
action
against climate change u.s governors
attended the summit but there was no
federal government representative
president donald trump pulled the
country out of the paris accord but in a
video released today
president-elect joe biden said the u.s
will rejoin the agreement on his first
day
in office coming up the battle between
australia and social media giants
there's long been a debate about how
tech giants have a huge sphere of
influence
just this week new york's attorney
general said no company should have this
much
unchecked power as mike delay reports
australia is looking at new laws
aimed at facebook and google they're
aiming high down under
australian lawmakers will soon be voting
on the news media bargaining code
legislation that would make facebook and
google pay for journalism
this is a huge reform this is a world
first
and the world is watching what happens
here in australia
the fight has been brewing for years in
countries all over the world
the tech giants use articles and stories
from broadcast and print media
yet don't share any of the ad revenue
they generate with the companies that
produce the work
and that's a significant amount of money
combined google and facebook control
76 of all online ad dollars in australia
our legislation will help ensure
that the rules of the digital world
mirror the rules of the physical world
now the counter argument has long been
that facebook and google drive
traffic to media websites however a
recent report in canada warned that
media is being starved out of
advertising revenue
with google and facebook controlling
between 60 and 90 percent of the digital
market
the fact is is that these large
communications organizations
have been making money off the backs of
canadian journalists for years
the news media canada report found that
at the same time newspaper ad revenue
plummeted 43
between 2014 and 2019 google's ad
revenues more than doubled
while facebook's increased five-fold and
the canadian association of broadcasters
predicts tv and radio here at home
will face revenue shortfalls of over a
billion dollars by 2022.
prime minister justin trudeau promised
to seek compensation for news content in
the most recent throne speech
but media watchers say they'll likely
wait and see what happens in australia
and that fight could get ugly with
australian media reporting facebook is
warning it might block
content rather than pay for it leaving
the australian government with no choice
but to play hardball it may be for a
time
to limit access
among australians to having access to
facebook which would not be a very
popular move i'm sure but there are ways
of
pushing back against these large media
companies
you can bet lawmakers around the world
are watching closely
mike turley global news toronto
there is international condemnation
tonight after iran executed a journalist
for his work that inspired the 2017
protests
over high levels of inflation and
unemployment for years rohala zam was
given asylum in france but last year he
was tricked into traveling to the middle
east
where he was abducted by iranian agents
today
he was hanged after iran's supreme court
held up his conviction
of fomenting violence the 47 year old
ran a website ahmad news which he used
to spread embarrassing information about
the president
and the ruling class a trio of code
breakers has cracked an
encrypted message 51 years after it was
sent to a san francisco newspaper
by the zodiac killer the serial killer
terrorized northern california in the
late 60s
taunting police and the public five
people were murdered
the decoded message doesn't reveal an
identity but part of it says
that wasn't me on the tv show suggesting
police were never on the right track
the fbi says the coded message was
solved by an american software developer
belgian programmer and australian
mathematician
still ahead brain fog the impact of cova
19
beyond a respiratory disease
the virus that's been plaguing the world
is best known for causing respiratory
illness
but the longer we live with it the more
we learn about kova 19's other effects
in some people it can cause debilitating
neurological symptoms
there can be confusion delirium and
strokes
even in those with mild symptoms donna
friesen looks into the work being done
by scientists to understand the impact
on the brain at first
erica taylor thought her symptoms were
just a sinus infection
i honestly didn't think that i had covet
but
i got tested as a precaution her results
came back
positive over the next six weeks she
developed severe headaches
started losing her memory and getting
confused
it feels like your brain is broken
doctors call it brain fog
a common term to describe neurological
issues that can include dizziness
memory loss and the inability to find
words
in november researchers found between 10
to 35 percent of covid19 survivors in
the u.s
experience similar disabling and
persistent neurological symptoms
here in canada scientists are recruiting
covid19 survivors to do mris on their
brains
tracking any changes the virus might
impact the brain in certain people
impairing their activities of daily
living and so this is a healthcare issue
in a societal issue
how covid gets in the brain is not clear
one theory is tied to the loss of the
sense of smell
that perhaps the virus invades the brain
through the nasal cavity
getting into the orbitofrontal cortex
the brain is covered with a membrane
called the dura
and the orbital frontal cortex actually
doesn't have any dura it's the only part
of the brain
that has this potential pathway and so
the virus can get in there graham says
there is evidence covid19 can migrate
from the orbitofrontal cortex
to other parts of the brain including
areas responsible for controlling
breathing and heartbeat so there are
examples of people who have
only had neurological symptoms and not
respiratory symptoms
and when it does it's life-changing
erica taylor still can't work she's on
medical
leave i'm still struggling a lot i don't
know
i don't know if i'll ever get to the
point where i'll be
be the same donna friesen global news
and donna we'll have more on the
theories about the virus and the loss of
smell tonight on the new reality
right here on global singer charlie
pride has died from complications due to
[Music]
covid19
pride was considered the first black
superstar in the world of country music
he won three grammys and was recently
honored with the willie nelson lifetime
achievement award
outside of music pride was an athlete he
played baseball for the negro american
league from 1952
through 1958 and he stayed a baseball
fan
in 2010 he became one of the owners of
the texas rangers
charlie pride was 86 years old
up next a sweet birthday surprise
reminds others
to reach out
this slippery scene in ukraine's capital
is getting a lot of attention
people struggle to walk on ice covered
streets
one poor soul just couldn't catch a
break she kept trying and trying
the police say the deep freeze caused
over a hundred car accidents in a single
day
and removing the ice took more than four
thousand sweepers
this next story may remind us of the
good there is in this world
an alberta woman couldn't stand the
thought of her grandma
celebrating her birthday alone turning
to social media the granddaughter
devised a sweet surprise
as jill croteau reports her ideas
sparked connections
across the country here's a nice
big one it's a chilly december day
this is one from william
he's in grade two but 95 year old rena
harris would willingly sit out here
all day long i can't believe it you're
95 years young what a milestone
savoring every single birth they wish
from people she's never even met
sincerely doreen stovey
isn't that nice yes saskatchewan
showing off a box full of treasured
notes and cards
it sounds like you are truly loved by
your family
she certainly is her granddaughter vicki
couldn't bear the thought of her
spending her special day alone
so she recruited some people on facebook
to drop a card in the mail
it just exploded so many people wanted
to write her
and it's been overwhelming a bit to be
honest you know that so many people want
to celebrate with her
oh it's just great
i just love mail but something even more
profound came from this call
out for cards it was very inspiring as
well because
people were writing back to me saying
you know because of this post i've
sent a letter to my grandma or you know
because of this
i've now called my grandma for the first
time in years you know and so
if at the end of the day it means people
are reaching out to their seniors
in their life you know um that's all i
could ever ask for
now i'll get emotional i thought it was
really really lovely heart warming and
i think my husband and i did a good job
raising her graham arena is planning on
sending thank you notes back to those
who
thought of her but you can count on this
feisty lady to include
one minor correction i tell them i'm
only
39. they got the wrong
number the best honestly
um i'm very blessed i could only wish
that any
everyone could have a grandma like mine
joe croteau global news
i'm sticking with 39 too that is global
national for this saturday i'm robin
gill
tonight your canada is tofino bc thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you